joining us now with more south carolina
senator lindsey graham is with us let me
put up on the screen senator this is joe
biden your old friend when he was a
little more coherent
and he voted to let states overturn roe
v wade right he backed an amendment to
our constitution to overturn roe v wade
um
you compare that to what i mentioned
earlier when i played earlier governor
northam and and some of these states
that allow abortion
even up until the moment of birth
which
by any scientific definition would be
murder uh by any scientific conclusion
if we're following science that child is
viable and can live alone outside the
womb
how did they get that extreme
well the most radical people in the
country maybe in the history of american
politics are now in charge of the
democratic party this is the democratic
party that wants to expand the supreme
court because they don't like the
conservative makeup this is the
democratic party that wants to put term
limits on judges our judges because they
don't like our judges this is the
democratic party that would abolish the
electoral college so delaware and south
carolina wouldn't have much of a say
about who's president it'd be new york
and california what happened to joe
biden he got hijacked by the most
radical people in the country he's
captive to their interest what happened
to the court today was the saddest
chapter in the history of the united
states supreme court this was despicable
it's dangerous and it was dumb to the
person who did this if it's a
conservative you're a traitor to the
cause if it's a liberal you're the
dumbest person in washington because
it's not going to change the midterms
you're not going to
scare any conservative judge away from
repealing roe v wade and it should be
repealed it should go back to the states
and you're adding a narrative to a story
line that you want to win and you don't
give a damn about how you win you want
to keep the seat open if you have to
destroy kavanaugh you want to change the
makeup of the court to make sure it
bends to your will you want open borders
to change the nature of america
you want abolished electoral college you
want to make d.c estate to make you more
powerful to those who want to gain power
through destroying institutions you're
going to get rejected at the ballot box
do you believe it's likely that this was
done to try to intimidate the justices
oh do you or do you believe maybe a
combination of intimidate them and
advance the narrative again to go back
to this idea of packing the court
well
the most likely scenario is that the
people who want to change institutions
to get their way did this the same
people who want to expand the court
because it's conservative why is it
conservative because people like you and
myself went out and voted for president
trump and conservatives to put
conservatives on the court they won't
expand the court to change its makeup
they want to do a electoral college so
that south carolina and other states
really can't have a say about picking
the president so i think their
motivation was to scare the court to
change his mind about repealing roe v
wade that's not going to work and to
create a debate to talk about something
other than high gas prices inflation and
broken borders and crime here's what i
think i don't think this decision by the
court if it holds is going to change the
midterm elections at all because people
are going to vote based on the safety
and the well-being of their family
not a supreme court decision all right
senator graham great to see you we
appreciate your analysis being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else